children from a single mother household
end up not doing well in school end up
more on drugs depression
jail the whole the whole thing whereas
versus a dual parent household typical
nuclear family the results are so much
better the anomaly in that is children
raised by just a father turn out to be
just as well as raised as in a
traditional nuclear family these are
kind of stats that you're referencing
100 go deeper on these stats what's your
biggest takeaway so my biggest takeaway
from that is that the man is is a
pivotal is a critical piece to to the
development of any child whether it's a
boy or girl okay so whenever you remove
that it come it comes to your mind it
just makes you think like is there
agenda behind this because we got all of
these societal Norms you got this
pressure you got consumerism that's
causing women to want to be you know
City girl lifestyle hot girl summer what
does that do to the nuclear family what
does that do to the kids